[Music]
being a transgender person we battle so
many fights on our own inside and when
you can conquer that and be your
authentic self there is nothing you
can't fight and win I enlisted in the
military because my family came to
America as refugees from Iran and I
wanted to give back to this country it
feels so good because you're doing
something so much bigger than yourself I
was assigned to a unit here in
California and they just totally like
swarm to me with compassion but I felt a
little scared at the time because I was
a lesbian and I was scared that people
were gonna know and how they were gonna
treat me because Don't Ask Don't Tell
had just been repealed I knew that I was
trans and I'm gonna be really cliche and
say my entire life my experience
transitioning while in the military has
been a really interesting one I started
my hormone replacement therapy when I
was 23 and I was about four years ago I
went and I sat down had a conversation
with my commander and I was prepared to
be discharged she's really really
emotional because I worked so hard to be
in the military I didn't want to just
get kicked out and he pulls out this
counseling statement just that I needed
to keep up with male grooming standards
I just started crying because it was I
was thinking I was gonna get kicked out
and Here I am having this amazing chain
of command that was just so supportive
for a lot of people in the military I
was the first trans person they had ever
met it was really awesome to be able to
sit down and explain to them what was
happening in who I am and how I felt the
end of the day when we got our missions
we put our minds together and we focused
on getting what needed to be done done
and that was it I do not think that
being transgender affects somebody's
ability to be in the military and to
serve this country honorably and
courageously as a matter of fact I think
being transgender is a positive thing
for the military and for this country as
a whole
cisgender people and allies and other
transgender people what they can do to
support trans servicemembers is continue
to talk about us continue to talk about
how great we are and how important we
are and how much strength and compassion
we bring to the military so there are a
lot of transgender people who have
reached out to me on social media and
Instagram that have expressed this like
really intense interest and passion for
wanting to serve in the military
what's happening now my advice to them
is don't stop if you want to serve in
this military go get and list it go talk
to a recruiter be your authentic self
don't hide anything don't lie just be
who you are and serve this country it's
the one thing that I will always say
whether you're cisgender whether you're
trans gay lesbian it does not matter who
you are never compromise your
authenticity for the comfort of others
[Music]